Marine accused of threatening a Mass
Attack on the Strip thank you for
joining us at six I'm Brian Loftus and
I'm Vanessa it's an arrest the 8 news
now in
naders told you about first news now
investigator David charns across the
studio breaking the story today David
what do we now know well source is
telling they use our investigators
police took this very seriously for a
couple of reasons first they say this
former Marine had access to
military-style weapons and second they
say they were concerned because of where
this man lives
foreign
rifle with a grenade launcher flashbangs
and Military ammunition they're just
some of the items Las Vegas Metro Police
say they found and seized from inside 41
year old Jeremy Schumacher's condo on
North Las Vegas Boulevard investigators
say on Monday Schumacher made threats to
quote carry out an act of mass violence
at Fashion Show Mall on the Strip the
person who alerted police is someone who
Schumacher knows but 8 news now is not
identifying them according to police
Schumacher threatened to kill the caller
their co-workers and himself he also
reportedly sent the caller a photo from
inside his apartment which police say
showed a quote heavily damaged door and
messages including I'm Coming For You
documents say the former Marine now
works as a graphic designer and police
became concerned when they learned
Schumacher's apartment had a direct View
High Above Fremont on street and
downtown Las Vegas Police also suspect
Schumacher quote maintained the ability
to carry out such an attack and had
exhibited warning signs of planning for
preparing for an attack
the Schumacher served in Afghanistan and
is identified in those court documents
we obtained first as a former Marine a
judge ordering him held on a million
dollars bail we did request to talk to
him today from jail but we were told he
was not available I'm David charns 8
news now Brian